after much speculation tom brady
officially announced his retirement from
football on tuesday the 44 year old is
hanging up his cleats and planning to
focus his energy elsewhere let's take a
look at the qb's lucrative career both
on and off the field as a six-round
draft pick brady went on to star for the
new england patriots and the tampa bay
buccaneers winning a total of seven
super bowls a surefire hall of famer
brady leads all quarterbacks in nfl
history with 84
520 passing yards and 624 passing
touchdowns
the three-time mvp achieved similar
success financially in his 22 years in
the nfl brady earned 293 million dollars
with his playing contracts according to
spa track additionally forbes estimates
he acquired more than 160 million
dollars from his off-field ventures
brady added entrepreneur to his resume
with his fitness and supplement company
tb12 media company 199 productions and
nft platform autograph which raised 170
million dollars in a recent round of
funding his endorsements include deals
with fanatics hertz subway and under
armour plus a massive sponsorship he
struck with cryptocurrency exchange ftx
forbes estimates brady was earning
around 12 million dollars off the field
as recently as the 2019 season but in an
nfl record this season pulling in 45
million off the field surpassing the 31
million dollars he posted in may when he
landed at number nine on forbes's annual
list of the world's highest paid
athletes with an estimated total upwards
of 450 million dollars brady leads the
nfl's all-time earnings exceeding
long-time rival peyton manning's
earnings who retired from the game after
18 seasons with an estimated 400 million
dollars
with his namesake apparel brand brady
line announced earlier this year various
sponsorship deals and entrepreneurial
endeavors brady has redefined how
football players can leverage their star
power
you